j'étais très fan de vous je crois que je
te l'aï déjà dit en fait j'avais des
posters trois posters donc dans ma
chambre de vous trois en taille réelle
et le soir avant d'aller dormir je vous
faisais un bisou sur la seconde à chacun
ses moyens dans ma chatte tellement je
vous kiffe et je vous étiez les trois
ans mezouza fihri il ya eu un drame dans
mes yeux un drame
en 2009 les drame qui nous a tous
marqués c'est évidemment le décès de
philippe septembre 2009
on va regarder on a retrouvé le jt de
tf1 mines qui ont parlé regarder il
incarnait le boys band à la française
filip nikolic est mort cette nuit à
l'âge de 35 ans il avait été le leader
des to beat feuz à la fin des années 90
avant de se lancer dans une carrière
d'acteur on le retrouvait régulièrement
sur tf1 aux côtés de roger hanin dans la
série navarro
son avocat a évoqué un abus de
somnifères c'était votre pote d'enfance
ouais ça ça quand quand vous quand vous
avez vu philippe repartir qu'est ce que
vous aviez vous êtes dit peut-être ça y
est on est on a eu tellement de succès
avant qu'après c'est peut-être ça qui a
fait que il n'a pas pu se remettre de
l'énorme succès avant toute chose moi je
n'avais pas de contact avec philippe
pratiquement huit mois avant qu'il soit
parti d'accord j'entendais des bruits
comme quoi ça n'allait pas et puis voilà
c'est qu'il sait permet bronzé qui était
angoissé et qui inquiète c'était un
extrême sur tout ce qui faisait donc il
faisait pas les choses à moitié quand il
dit quelque chose
voilà c'était le coup de trop le soir
aussi les parties c'était à la fois de
trop oui bernard il avait quand même il
faut le dire
oser le dire il a quand même péter les
plombs un moment franchement c'est moi
je les ai connus depuis le début tu te
souviens vous veniez même chez moi et
faire des chorégraphies tout ça que
j'avais le loft dans le deuxième et j'ai
connu des débuts même avant que le
disque sorte mais est un moment cette
autorité telle cette folie lui qui a
toujours rêvé d'être une star et bombo
got les trois beaux gosses et celles ci
sont rentrés dans une folie incroyable
un truc incroyable ya eu le fric les
boîtiers tohu et au bout d'un moment il
a un peu pété les plombs messager dans
la pratique
cwi question non je voulais donc
simplement dire cela c'est
qu'effectivement il a rompu à peu avec
tout le monde
le succès n'était plus là donc ça a été
très difficile pour lui de le vivre
après même avec la série où il a réussi
à tourner sur wayne navarro avec tf1 il
y avait plus de projets derrière c'était
assez compliqué entre temps il a eu un
enfant et il était avec sa famille et
c'était très lesquels télévisuelle pour
lui d'un angoissé alors qu'ils aient du
travail ou pas c'était quelqu'un au fur
et à mesure qu'ils qui intérieurement
qui n'allait pas de toute façon donc que
ce soit avec ou sans succès c'est
quelqu'un qui n'allait pas la jeune déjà
il avait un problème d'existence je les
avais besoin de plaire à tout le monde
comment la mère de benjamin avait essayé
avec roger hanin de le prendre un petit
peu en charge dans brigade navarro
essayé de le raisonner il disait et
parent sucette c'est impossible de de
l'aider c'est en tout cas c'est vrai que
c'était un il était très très bon dans
tout cet environnement très très bon
dans tout ce qu'il faisait